donc essayez de l'info qui datent de 48
heures c'est pour ça d'avant hier
c'est un petit peu calculé 48 ans à 41
way est par contre beaucoup les jeux les
revues et fait elle parle des français
qui ont beaucoup de mal à s'endormir
ah oui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ouais et français dans moins de sept
mais toi tu dors pas du tout le pari non
je dors pas ça c'est alors qu'à
l'antenne
c'est vrai le proviseur paf c'est un
truc de ouf j'ai l'insomnie des deux
trois heures par nuit
crois tu m'appelles pas bac et moi faire
un jeu bottes dérange et dérangera canet
merci tu es mon frère est un frère veut
m'appeler jour et nuit c'est vrai bah
oui ok france indoor moins de moins en
moins moins de sept heures par nuit qui
a pas et à part vous vous dormez
beaucoup n'ont pas pas du tout
et pourquoi j'ai peut-être dont nous est
fainéant non repartir et le principal
défaut de bernard non on les traite vous
dormez combien de hangu non non non moi
je me couche tard il n'y a pas de danger
sincèrement cette heure ci cette heure
benhaim ouais ouais 6 heures beinheim
j'appelle tous les matins et toujours
éveillé bah oui à 100 et c'est un truc
de fou parce que je l'appelle pour les
chiffres tous les matins je commente ces
chiffres d'audience
la fej et les producteurs en ligne qui
le matin 9 heures merci aujourd'hui 4 5
heures mais pas la nuit dans la journée
à la nuit je dors pas mais la journée en
revanche vous vous vous moi il me faut 8
mai en moyenne j'adore 7 heures à 8
heures je suis bien à cette heure ça va
pas vous 14h12 alors fait elle tue vous
dira sa journée aller simple en l2 or la
règle ici
[Applaudissements]
minuit ce côté là elle merci tu
qu'écologiste amer ce côté là je vous
aime beaucoup mais je m'en fous qu'est
ce que parce qu'on a bien gêné comme moi
parce que je dors 2h 2h30 on peut faire
à faire ce qu'il fait on l'aimé naka
manche de recettes
s'il vous plaît déjà andy violence et
déjà individuellement les deux sens où
il ne fait pas de duo les gens sont l'on
peut pas dire que c'est un truc de fou
mais tendu où on est marin on ferme on
n'allait pas d'alcool prévu uniquement
j'arrive à dormir c'est très drôle